all right so my name is Shahid Barket
Joseph Tierney and we are the co
developers of Auto impute which is a
package and today we're gonna be talking
about all the above and to end what is
the challenge that we're trying to solve
why how we actually go about that
through a four-step approach and then
really go into the auto impute package
itself speak to what it does how it
works and then a demonstration of it is
a specific use case so where you can
actually use it so what is the challenge
so what is the issue that we're trying
to solve here and kind of both Brad
alluded to it's like the bane of our
existence the first thing that we we do
in this slide or in this beginning is
we're gonna create a dataset so create a
bunch of data points we're gonna create
a data set of containing x and y
variables and then we're gonna add
missingness and so we had 20%
missingness and x 30% missingness and y
and then we show you a plot of it so
simply put there is a bunch of data
points XY in a plot this shows some
correlation and there's some missingness
in this data so the next step then is
for most of us is okay let's put this
into a machine learning model supervised
machine learning model and try to get
prediction and so we use scikit-learn
popular python package to do that and
we're gonna do a linear regression X as
a predictor Y is a response variable and
let's see what happens well it fails it
gives you an error and the reason is
because you have missing data which all
of us know so any type of machine
learning model that you do a
scikit-learn is going to give you this
error because you have missing values so
this was the fundamental premise that we
worked off of is what do you do now when
you get in this scenario when you have
missing this what do you do as a data
engineer data scientist well you have to
look at the whole pipeline and so our
package focuses on the end-to-end
analysis of this pipeline starting with
the missing data itself by exploring the
missing us in a data set you can
actually understand how you're missing
this occurs and then from there at that
point you need to make a decision and
the two most common choices that people
make are well I'm gonna do list wise
deletion I'm gonna remove
all the values that have missing
observations and therefore I'll have a
full data set that I can run into my
machine learning model and get
predictions off of okay valid valid
option second option is do imputation
imputation as many of you know is the
process of filling in missing values
with values using a variety of different
tens and hundreds of different methods
or algorithms that you can use for
imputation
so one of the problems with that is how
do you choose which is the right one for
your dataset and two if you do choose
one how do you even understand what
you're impure is actually doing to the
dataset and then you take that and you
put it into your linear regression for
example and you get a prediction and a
coefficient you get a coefficient and
you use that for predictions but what is
actually happening what is the effect of
that decision that you made on your data
set that's actually leading to this
output and so our package focuses on
that piece is the effect of imputation
on a data set leading in to analysis and
so is there a package yes there is auto
impute is the package to do this there
are others as well but this is the one
that we built in Python focused on the
analysis and the end-to-end analysis for
this and so we have a four-step approach
first is understand the messiness in
your data step one always is what is
going on in the data set and what is the
missingness look like the second step is
then understand why that messiness
actually occurred in the data set and so
there's something called the missing
data mechanism that will speak into
further in the background section but
basically understanding why that
missingness occurred in your data set
the third is we're gonna use our package
to then try a bunch of different
imputation methods to see what effect it
has on the data set when you're filling
in values using these methods and then
lastly we're gonna run that new data set
each one iterated into a linear
regression and see what is the output of
that on the coefficients the bias and
the variance of the the output that you
get and
see the actual effect that it's having
into the analytical model at the end and
so going into the background well we
first need to understand is the missing
data mechanism so there's three types of
missing data mechanisms the first is
missing completely at random mcar and
the fundamental premise here is that
mcar is anytime there is missingness
with an equal probability of missingness
so know no matter what's going on
the chance of being missing is equal and
so mcar is a very strict condition and
most often times in the real world we
don't see this but this is the
fundamental the starting point is mcar
data sets the second and less strict is
missing at random ma r and this example
is focused on the probability of a
variable being missing based on the
actual observed variables themselves and
it'll be easier when I go through the
example of actually understanding what
this means but for now just take my word
for it and then the last piece is
missing not at random which is now we're
actually miss causing missingness in our
data set that is actually the
probability of it happening is based on
the unobserved variables so we have no
idea what's actually causing that
messiness and therefore we need to model
that missingness itself to really
understand why it's not at random and
that is the reason there is this concept
of ignore ability and that is the
assumption that we will start with
anytime we're doing any type of
imputation is that if we have a missing
at random or missing completely at
random data set because it is based on
either equal probability of missingness
or the observed values we can claim that
they are ignoring and therefore we can
then impute them missing not at random
we would have to model the misenus to
understand why it's missing and
therefore it becomes much larger
challenge so let's take the scope of
this conversation we're only going to be
focusing on missing completely at random
m-car and missing at random so to show
you an example what this means is let's
see for example everyone in this room we
were doing a weight loss contest and the
first step is we're gonna get everyone's
starting weight
well missing completely at random is
everyone's getting on the scale and
randomly for whatever reason the battery
dies and we're no longer able to collect
data for weights and that isn't based on
any other thing except the battery died
it's not based on you know if you're
tall or short or have you're skinny it's
just because the battery died
missing clear an equal probability that
it's going to be missing the second is
missing at random which is that now
you're missingness is dependent on a
known variable and that known variable
is whether or not the surface that we
weighed you on was soft or hard so
anytime we weighed you in a hard surface
we got your data point we got your
weight anytime you were on a soft
surface we did not get your data point
you're not get your weight and if we
know that we measured you on a hard
surface versus a soft surface we could
use that known variable than to actually
impute those values and therefore it's
missing at random and the last piece
here is missing not at random which is
anyone who was over a certain weight
they were too heavy we did not capture
their data set their data point or their
weight and because that scale just could
not scale right so that's missing not at
random entire group of people because of
an unobserved variable is missing
because of their weight is too heavy so
hopefully that makes sense because this
is the foundation of what we're gonna
talk about all our examples are based on
understanding missing completely at
random and missing at random data sets
so once we understand the mechanism for
missing this you know our next step is
generally to pick a strategy to deal
with that missing this now the
strategies we go over here have their
pros and cons depending on the type of
missingness that exists but first we'll
just go into what those strategies are
and how a process generally works to
impute missing data so as we mentioned
earlier the two general strategies are
deletion and imputation right so
deletion involves removing records from
a data set that are missing and just
discarding those rows altogether you
know that can often be fine if your
sample size is large in the MS
in that sample size is relatively small
but if you know the amount of missing
data starts to grow you can't just start
throwing out rows that will lead to
often a reduction in power for
statistical models you know it will lead
to much larger larger standard errors in
modeling because you're discarding you
know important valleys in your dating
data set so what we focus on mainly and
this is imputation an imputation can
come in many forms right it's the first
to start there can be univariate and
multivariate imputation univariate
imputation uses a feature or a vector
itself and characteristics of that
vector to impute missing values so you
could take you know weight for example
and you could take the mean of the
weight and fill in anything that's
missing with the mean of your sample
that would be univariate because you're
not using any other features in your
data set multivariate imputation would
be using other features such as age such
as the scale surface right to determine
whether or not you you know you use a
specific value for weight as an
imputation right um then once you've
picked imputation strategies you know
the question is how many times should
you do those amputations you know and so
the example here walks through starting
with you know missing data then doing
single imputation where you impute
missing values one time only and then we
show multiple imputation where you
impute the same missing values multiple
times right and so why we would do this
might seem counterintuitive at first but
it's important to remember here that you
know missing values themselves are
unknown right so because they're unknown
we're not trying to find you know point
estimates for them we're not trying to
find the perfect values for them we're
trying to capture the fact that we don't
know the true value right so multiple
imputation helps us capture the
variability when imputing values that we
don't actually know right so here you
know in single imputation 25 and 18 if
we were to use those alone right we'd
essentially be subbing in those values
and saying that we're searching that
these are the values for what was you
know previously missing right so
multiple imputation is the frame
that allows us to impede the same
variable multiple times and in doing so
as we see later in the presentation we
can capture the variability between
amputations and actually start to say
things about you know the missingness
itself so if we look at this pipeline in
regression right how would we do
regression with multiple imputation so
we start with that same example
incomplete data right we perform
multiple imputation using imputation
methods which we'll get to some examples
later after that we run a an analysis
model in this case linear regression on
each imputed data set separately right
so we see here we actually end up with
three models one for each of the imputed
data sets obviously those models will be
different because the imputations in
each data set are different and then the
final goal is to pool those models in
some way to give us one final model
right and so that one final model will
have coefficients but it will also have
additional metrics that you know can
help us understand the variability
between amputations and how certain we
are about this coefficient or how you
know reliable we think it is you know
based on the variability in our
amputations so that is the pipeline that
we've put forth to do regression using
multiple imputation and that should be
you know enough of the background
information it's kind of dig into the
package before we do that some
considerations that we wanted to you
know put out there before going into a
demo before looking at the package you
know are these four bullet points right
so it's important to understand the
missing data mechanism and pick
imputation methods based on that what
you're doing here again is not you know
trying to find point estimates for
missing values you're not necessarily
trying to predict things what you're
trying to do is preserve relationships
in the data that you're imputing right
so if you're imputing you know one
variable you want to preserve you know
the variance the distribution of that
missing variable
the marginal distribution of that
variable itself you also want to
preserve you know the covariance
structure between imputed variables and
variables that you might not be imputing
and yeah and and again you know in that
it's it's important to remember that
imputation is not prediction the last
thing here to clarify that's not on this
slide is this all is under the
assumption of you know ignore ability
right so here we're assuming that the
distributions that govern you know the
observed data are the same that govern
the missing data right and so that's why
we want to essentially preserve those
distributions and the covariance between
features if we actually had data that
was MNAR a lot of this would become a
lot more complicated because the missing
data itself might be governed by a
separate distribution right so with that
in mind we can go into the package so
yes it's name is Auto impute getting
started
right so obviously it's on the Python
packaging index you can pip install it
and we designed it to be simple and
familiar right so it follows the same
API is scikit-learn and but it can also
be very flexible right as we'll see in
subsequent slides you can get started
very very simply or you can you know
take control over the in pewter and the
regression models right to do a lot of
custom you know and complex stuff so you
know the heart of this is really the
multiple in Peter the NI linear
regression model as we saw you know a
couple of slides ago actually just uses
a multiple and Peter under the hood
before pulling neon estimates and
spitting out a final regression model
but looking at the multiple and Peter
itself yes so a few things I just
mentioned
same design as scikit-learn so you know
creating an instance of the multiple in
peter peter class is pretty
straightforward all of the formal
arguments have default values when we
print the in pewter we you know leverage
the base estimator from scikit-learn to
you know have a good representation of
the class object right and then it also
subclasses that transformer mix in so
the methods of the class should be
familiar right fit transform and fit
transform you know and so it follows a
very easy
you know an intuitive design so that you
can start leveraging it as soon as
possible
yeah so one look at the formal arguments
here right as we see in this example
there's default values for for all of
them we'll get into more detail about
what those are on the next slide when we
show a more complex example of the
multiple and Peter yeah so in this case
let's go through some of the arguments
right so here we're basically
customizing our multiple and Peter
tailoring it to do what we want so first
n the number of imputation the
imputation rounds you want to complete
the strategy argument allows you to
specify the strategy you want to use for
imputation and you can specify that by
column right so in this case you know we
have a salary column then we want to use
P mm which is predictive mean matching
and we have a gender column and we might
want to use binary logistic regression
for that right so we can use different
imputation methods for different columns
the predictors argument similarly allows
you to specify which columns you want to
use to impute specific variables right
so here we see in strategy salary P mm
and the predictors we want to use every
other column right but for gender we
only want to use salary in education
right so we can actually limit the
predictors that we use to impute other
variables M kwargs is essentially
another argument that lets you further
customize the actual imputation methods
themselves right so P mm is a hybrid
method you know between like Bayesian
regression and kN
and so with you know Bayesian methods in
pi MC 3 you can specify you know a
number of arguments right so what you
can actually do is put them in the imp
cogs and further customize you know the
different strategies that you use right
so you know you can change the number of
neighbors for K and n from five to ten
you know and basically control what pmm
does what logistic regression does and
those models will all follow whatever
the package or the strategy that we're
using is and we have that you know
documented as well the last two the
visit sequence is the way in which you
impute columns so by default it's
left-to-right
but you can also impute columns in
different orders and the last one return
list here I set it equal to true which
means that all of the imputations will
run right away by default you know that
can you know actually lead to you know
pretty expensive computation so by
default it evaluates lazily and just
returned to generator but the point of
showing this is that there's a lot that
you can do with a multiple computer
besides just create you know a class
instance you can kind of customize it as
you see fit for any situation
and this does handle you know
categorical and you know continuous
variables okay so the main features I
won't go too much into this but you know
the point of this package is to be
end-to-end from you know exploring
missingness visualizing missingness
doing different imputation strategies
and actually doing you know regressions
on multiply imputed data for the demo
we're going
oh and these are all of the methods that
our package currently supports for the
demo that we go into next we're going to
focus on three methods and we're gonna
walk through the engined example from
imputation to regression with some
visualization along the way that will
hopefully bring a lot of the dry
background kind of more into a practical
example right so the three imputation
methods we've chosen are mean imputation
linear regression imputation and
predictive mean matching okay so now we
will go into a demonstration where
hopefully all of what we just said will
you know be a little bit more practical
and explain alright alright so the the
demonstration we're gonna do is gonna
focus on two separate data sets the
first one is gonna be MC a are I missing
completely at random so what we've done
here is we've created a data set that's
500 observations we then created
correlation between two variables x and
y of 0.7 and then we artificially
created missingness in the form of
missing completely at random and the
missing variable in here is y so x is
full
observed and why is 40% missing and so
what we're basically doing is creating a
data set that's missing completely at
random and only one variable has
missingness but the two variables are
correlated at point seven and we're
gonna do exactly what Joe said we're
gonna do three imputation methods to
show you the difference that each one
has on this data set mean these squares
and PMM the second data set that we'll
walk through is missing at random so
same idea 500 observations that we
created are 0.7 correlation and we
created artificial missingness it's
mimicking missing at random and the key
point here to understand is X is now the
missing variable 40% and Y is fully
observed and you will see why that's the
case and then we walk through the same
same three imputation methods to show
you the difference between mcar
and mnar and how the missing data type
missing data mechanism actually affects
the imputation methods used to impute
those data sets I think one more point
to make on that is that you know here
the process the code is exactly the same
right what we're highlighting is that
while the methods that we introduced you
know mean least squares and pmm work
across any data set you give it the
result will be you know dramatically
different right so you know missing data
imputation is I think a cross between
you know domain expertise you know
understanding why missing data might
exist in your field and then you know
picking the strategies that best handle
the type of missingness as well as the
location of missingness right so missing
this missing this within you know an
independent variable is different than
missing this within a dependent variable
right so that's kind of the the point of
this example but the actual code you
know step by step is exactly the same
okay so first we'll start with the
missing completely at random example
right so step one in our four-step
process was to visualize missingness
itself right so our package has plots to
do that right in this case
mcar is a data frame and we're passing
it to the two different functions that
plot you know missing this and help us
understand you know missing this in our
data set right so the one on the Left we
see you know variable Y you know here
the black bars represent the number of
observed so here we see that you know
why only has 284 observed right so
roughly 40% of Y are missing relative to
X the plot on the right shows the
locations of missingness within our data
frame right so because you know in this
case X is fully observe great that's why
we get a black rectangle the important
part is on the on the right here with Y
the white bars represent missing rows
records and we don't see any pattern in
them right they are evenly distributed
throughout the vector and they have no
relation to X right so if we saw for
example more whiteness toward the bottom
we would know that you know the
likelihood of missingness or the
probability of being missing increases
as the value of x increases right and so
looking at this graph really helps us
reason about whether we're dealing with
mcar or MA are right and we should also
note that you know there's no formal
test for MA are right so you have to
kind of use inference right you know to
some degree right and so starting with
understanding your data and visualizing
it in this way can help you be you know
much more confident about the next step
which is you know handling that missing
data via imputation or deletion hey and
just add that's why we've been kind of
harping on the missing data mechanism so
much is that it's critical to understand
and there is no formal method or
statistical method to prove that a data
set is missing completely random missing
at random or missing not at random which
is why you as the data engineer need to
use your domain expertise and knowledge
of your data set and visualizations like
this to infer which one you think it is
and then work backwards based on the
imputation method cool so the next step
here you know we start with mean
imputation will show a little more code
on this slide in the next slide then
subsequent slides just to you know
explain how they happen right but in
this case we've already done the
imputation right and we're doing
multiple imputation with each imputation
we have five rounds right so in that
framework we use mean as one example
least squares as another example PMM as
the final example when we get to pmm
I'll go into it a little more but mean
observation is the simplest or mean
imputation is the simplest each of the
five rounds we impute the mean of of Y
right
it's a univariate method we don't use
any other information in the data set
and as a result every imputation is the
same right so if we look at the left
plot there's no variability in Y in one
to five right they're all stacked on top
of each other right and what we've done
is you know created five rounds of
imputations that essentially you know we
could have done with one right you know
so the subsequent rounds with mean
imputation don't add anything and then
we've also distorted the marginal
distribution of Y here because I mean
imputation you know will shrink the
variance right given that we're just
essentially imputing the mean these two
plots right are how we kind of visualize
that there again native to you know the
audio impute package and they help us
look at you know what imputation has
done to the distribution of the imputed
feature itself right the next plot here
the one on the left helps us look at you
know where the imputed values actually
are right again with mean imputation
each round you know the blue values are
all of the observed the red values are
the imputed we can see imputing the mean
doesn't really add much to the data set
itself and then on the right we can see
the results of how mean imputation will
distort the correlation between x and y
and as a result will distort or bias you
know any regression weights and stay
our estimates one thing to note here
which we'll see in the regression
analysis this is pooled standard error
so when we do multiple imputation we
need to take into account the variance
that occurs between each imputation
round as well as normal standard area
that occurs within you know a regular
regression right so in this case because
the mean is just imputing the same value
every single time right there's no
additional variability and a regression
will be too confident you know in it's
biased weight so you know mean if you
taken is really not useful in practice
but it is a good starting point to
understand the types of things that can
arise when you don't pick imputation
methods carefully so least squares makes
some improvements right so and mean
again X is completely disregarding any
relationship with y least squares at
least considers that relationship by
imputing values based on the line of
best fit between y and x in the case of
mcar will see that mean imputation leads
to an unbiased regression right again
when y itself the dependent variable is
missing completely at random then the
model you're building to impute missing
values will be the same as the model you
actually use for regression so it won't
actually bias the regression wait but
what it will do is inflate the
correlation between the two variables
right because you're imputations are
along the line of best fit right so when
you impute with linear regression you're
removing any noise you know in those
missing values and saying that they all
lie along the line of best fit right so
that will artificially inflate the
correlation between y and X and in
practice this is still using it's
dangerous because the results are going
to look very good but you know in fact
you know while that might be good for
prediction you know what you're doing is
putting way too much confidence in a
model and disregarding all of the you
know variability you know that we think
is important to consider the next one is
p.m. M so p.m. M is as I mentioned
earlier
method what you're essentially doing is
in is creating a Bayesian regression
right and your we also support Bayesian
regression where you basically sample
from the predictive posterior
distribution and use this to impute here
what you're doing is creating
predictions predicted values for
imputation using a Bayesian regression
model then you're taking those values
and you're finding like the five or ten
nearest neighbors from within the
observed values you know of the feature
right so essentially what you're doing
is saying okay well based on my
prediction what values that are already
observed or kind of close to this and
you take those values and then you
actually substitute those is the
imputation right so the reason this is
important is because again we consider
you know mcar and ma are right so what
you're basically doing is saying you
know where are the areas where missing
this is the highest right what are the
values around that area that are
actually observed which ones can I pull
from and just put those as the
imputation right the important thing
here with the graphed on the left is
this is the first method that actually
introduces randomness between imputation
methods that's why we have five lines
that don't stack on top of each other
right and and this is where we actually
start to look at how well methods
perform under certain conditions right
so later on we'll see an MA our example
where pmm does a lot better here with
MCA are the missing this is all
throughout the data set right so pmm
can't really focus in on one area it's
constantly pulling different values from
different areas and imputing right and
in doing that right sometimes the
distribution is better than then you
know it is in the next case and we kind
of see that with this graphed on the
Left right so the first imputation for
pmm focused on imputing a lot of values
that ended up being lower the other ones
were you know more thorough but we'll
see that you know the graphed on the
right PMM respects not only you know the
the target variable that it's imputing
but also the relationship between that
variable
in the data set right so in this in this
case you know what we show is that PMM
out of these three does the best and we
kind of pull all of those different
metrics that we had on the last slides
right into a table here and then show
actual regression results if we had
imputed data using multiple imputation
and then pooled the different you know
parameters into one final regression so
in this case that first slide where we
pool all of our different models on
specific imputations you know comes to
fruition here and we get one you know
standard error coefficient one you know
regression weight and then variants
within and variance between variants
between is between each imputation round
so we can see pmm is the only one that
actually introduces any randomness okay
so next we'll go through an example of
missing at random using so the same data
said that we had mentioned in the
beginning except in this case Y is fully
observed X is 40% missing so same code
as Jo is mentioning in the first example
we're going to run do the same exercise
in the second example and show you the
differences that we see so in this you
see the exact same playing Y is full you
observed X has around 40% missingness
the difference though that you will see
in the right plot and I think Joe
alluded to this was that you see that
the white lines are more toward the
bottom of the graph on the right side on
the right picture which is basically
saying that our missingness is more
focused in areas where Y is higher and
that's why it's missing at random so
going back to my point in understanding
and inferring which missing data
mechanism it is if you were to see
something like this and you were trying
to see something like this you could see
that because there's more white spaces
at the bottom this is missing at random
versus the other graph that we saw it
was completely evenly distributed
missingness that's an important key
point to know and because YX have a you
know strong correlation here if the
value of y is where there's you know if
higher values of Y lead to more
missingness an X than those imputed
values should you know for X should be
higher as well right and that's one
thing we'll see that you know some
the models aren't able to do very well
if they don't respect the pattern yes so
similar to the first graph mean
imputation right we see a big peak but
the key difference here that you'll
notice is that mean is biased and why
that is is Joe's alluding to is that
because more of our values in X were
missing at the higher end of Y we're
losing out on those values in our mean
calculation so a perfect example is you
had a data set between 1 to 10 and all
you're missing this was at the end so
you missed 8 9 and 10
well 1 through 7 your mean is gonna be
around 3.5 versus a 5 and so our biases
actually move forward and shifted sorry
or mean a shifted and therefore biased
to the shorter end of the scale and you
see that in this graph where the mean is
actually shifted left and so not only do
you get this mixed big pipe oh my god
excuse me big peak and because of the
mean imputation but also it's shifting
it and biasing it in missing at random
it's like a point similar graph we see
that mean imputation does not do well
because of obvious reasons it doesn't
take into account the correlation
between x and y and therefore we have a
single line of imputation around in X
and if anyone's interested in that
complicated we can talk after yeah the
standard your competition but you talk
after the session but least squares same
idea we have multiplied imputed 5 times
but because it's the line of best fit
everyone is going to be exactly the same
therefore we see them stacked on a
single line line of best fit and yes it
although it does better than mean
imputation and maintaining that
distribution as we see in the next slide
it also is is doing the same thing that
we saw in missing completely at random
which is narrowing our imputations on
the line of best fit and because again
on the right side here we see that the
higher values of X were missing we're
not taking them into account which is
why our line of best fit in this diagram
is actually off from where it should be
in the data set it's actually more
higher peak it should be a little bit
lower and because that's the higher
use of X that it's missing out on and
because linear regression only focuses
on the observed data it has no idea of
the larger missing values that it's
missing right so here's an example where
the mcar example had an unbiased
coefficient right and applying that same
example with different circumstances and
the data leads to completely different
results you know in your imputation and
then eventually in your analysis model
and then same thing pmm we so Joe
alluded to this as well in missing clear
random it was a little bit more varied
actually maybe a lot more varied in each
imputation itself but because the
missingness and missing at random is
focused in an area where Y is larger
it's better able to in each imputation
iteration better able to track that and
incorrectly impute and therefore each
one of those lines a little bit closer
to each other the variance between us is
closer and as we see there's a lot more
red in the higher of it and areas of
missingness therefore pmm is doing a
better job of imputing the missingness
at the higher end and also maintaining
the distribution of the data set and
between x and y because we're short on
time right I think one of the good
things to note here it is
we've seen the first two methods kind of
degrade as things become a little bit
more complicated
you know pmm of these three is the most
robust to handle mcar and ma are you
know and so if you're going to use
something out of the bat right I would
use pmm it's actually the default for
continuous variables in auto imputed
that exact reason some of the other
methods can be useful in different areas
you know but one of the things that we
note on these slides right is that you
know in in none of these areas do we say
best or do we rank them from you know
top to bottom right it's very dependent
on you know all of the different factors
right and in some cases you know pmm
will do better in some cases it won't
you know and and and it really just
depends on you know all of these
considerations that we've had and then
what's important to you right so if all
you care about is regression weights and
you don't care about standard error
right
you might not necessarily need to use
pmm for all use cases it can be
prohibitively expensive on larger
datasets right so there's a lot of
things to take into consideration and
you know the method depends on a lot of
factors and yeah and that's why the key
point here is to go through this
four-step approach
understand the messiness in your data
set then that will help you understand
what type of missing data mechanism is
at play here
and if it doesn't then you can go
through the imputation process and
you'll very quickly see that certain
imputation methods are really bad for
certain data sets and so that's why
we're saying that we're not going to
recommend from auto impute the best
imputation method we're going to give
you the tools so that you can do the
analysis and use your best judgment
because you have the domain expertise as
well as the knowledge in your own data
set so go through the steps understand
the missingness understand the machine
native mechanism try different
imputation methods run them through
analytical models and really understand
what's happening and that way you can
better make a decision on what's best
for you and so real quick we wanted to
jump into some of the content that we
have yes there's talking get happen then
we have a website last thing yeah we
have a website with a number of
tutorials that have like extensive code
to walk through and explain all the
different features of the package and
they probably do a better job than we
can you know out loud in 45 minutes so
and then lastly and we have a lot of
future work and you know are looking
actively looking for contributors so if
anyone's actually interested in getting
involved today there's tons of
additional methods there's you know
doing this on larger datasets there's
integrating desk and you know Numbi
arrays and other things like raisin
they're things like that so and yeah
that's pretty much it
yes our kind of call to action here is
go out there pip install to impute try
it let us know your feedback good things
bad things and we'd love to get
information from you all so thank you
for the time
[Applause]
for this presentation and for creating
this great package for everybody take
advantage of it this is a common problem
I know everyone's probably here face so
we have some time for questions we left
this run a little bit long because there
was really great content here so maybe
just a few questions now and we could
probably catch up with these guys at the
breaks so more than about the package
this is probably a more general
conceptual question if the intention is
to keep the distribution same with the
imputation how is that really different
it's not really adding a changing the
entropy if you were to just exclude
those those missing values so if there
is no new no change in entropy there's
no change in information like I'm trying
to like figure out what's what's really
the advantage of computing in that case
yeah I think that's a good point
yeah so the question was what is the
actual value of imputing if by missing
by removing observations there's no
effect to the change of information that
DSM provides or the entropy of that data
set right yeah and I think to start
right in some cases removing
observations from the data set is
actually the best method right in cases
where you have extremely large data sets
it's mcar and the amount of missingness
is relatively small then discarding that
missing this likely won't affect your
model it's also much easier to just drop
missing records right in cases where the
missingness is MA are right if you drop
missing records you actually might be
losing information for example if you're
missing this is all based off you know
like a tail end of the distribution
right and you remove all those records
right essentially you'll be losing a lot
of information that actually is
important right
the example that shad gave owes you know
it's important there and and when you
drop them it might not actually mean
much for the distribution itself but
when you try to use that feature
you know in a regression for example and
you use that feature as say a dependent
variable or start has an independent
variable then it starts to introduce a
lot of bias downstream even though it
might not look like it had a negative
effect on the variable itself right and
for the example that I did missing at
random you saw that the higher values of
Y had a lot of missingness and X so if
you were to remove those if you were to
ever do a use in a linear regression you
would miss out on the higher end values
of X itself and so it would affect the
information that's actually provided a
data set and that is because it's
missing at random and the way that it
was missing at random your your question
is I would say accurate for missing
completely at random large data sets
with small messiness yes it makes sense
to remove those missing values you're
not missing anything in terms of
information and also it's
computationally more efficient than
imputing how do you consider the
relationships of different experts like
for sometimes if you have a number of
independent variables in your model and
they're kind of cool together and
because according to the mice imputation
algorithm if you're using that it will
basically looking for other numerical
variables and they're kind of making
subgroups and imputing of missing values
so I'm just curious how you do you
consider the relationships of other
experiments yes the question is how do
you consider the relationships of
multiple different independent variables
while imputing in our package and so
that's a great question so the first
point is that when you impute a variable
it there's a difference between like an
analysis model and an imputation model
right so let's say your variable is y
and you have X 1 and X 2 right and
ultimately you want to create a model
you know for Y with X 1 and X 2 is
independent variables right when X 1 and
X 2 are being imputed they actually
become the target variable and Y and X
to impute X 1 right and then Y and X 1
and X 2 right so for the imputation
model itself
you know it's you're not looking at the
relationship between x1 and x2 you know
on why but this the second part of that
is that like interactions between you
know independent variables is extremely
important right now or is is just you
know treating them all as independent
right that's one thing that we want to
work on and you know essentially you
know that's a huge issue in general
right and you reference the you know
nice package raise that was like an
inspiration for a lot of this and that
package actually goes into like
multi-level modeling interactions
between terms now to handle that right
so that's one thing we hope to get to
and if you'd like to help work on it
so yeah submit a pull request but but
for now I mean I think Joe went over in
his multiple imputation the complex
example we gave you the option to use
multiple independent to impute a single
independent variable or vice versa but
that's kind of dependent on you
understanding the interaction that's
already there between your independent
variables and so that's right now that
is a that is what we're we're at right
now
all right this is going to be a quick
one so I'm just wondering if there's one
variable that has a missing value and
there's a reason this variable has
something Sumeria but from looking at
this variable versus other variable we
couldn't tell was the connection but for
me it makes more sense to create a
missing indicator but how would this
package resolve that problem
yeah so if there was a yeah I think the
one is you know in what like why
wouldn't you just create a missing
indicator right and use the missing
indicator as its own variable right is
that right and and again I would say
that that is similar to why wouldn't you
just delete right there are places where
that is appropriate we didn't focus on
the indicator variables in this case but
you know the short answer and we can go
into more detail is that sometimes that
also leads to bias if you use an
indicator variable
in like the wrong situations there's
actually a good passage about that in an
article I can refer you to that might be
the best for now so but it's similar to
the list the list wise delete example
right in some cases that works
completely fine in other cases that
leads to complications is the short
answer
all right let's wrap this up we're
really just a little bit over time now
appreciate everybody coming today and
one more Hannibal applause